what's going on guys this is rob and
fingers crossed we get some kind of an
announcement for deadpool at d23 this
week and otherwise this video may not do
very well but i'm kind of curious to see
how you guys feel about the thunderbolts
so here's the thing the thunderbolts as
a team historically speaking have kind
of been marvel's answer to like the
suicide squad from dc comics albeit
without everybody dying over the course
of the story and being replaced by
somebody else but this is technically
the second iteration or the second
volume of thunderbolts the first one
being the team that was led by baron
zemo during the events of civil war so
what this does is this initially picks
up with frank castle of course basically
being held captive by a bunch of guys
who have all essentially been killed and
then somebody else essentially talking
to him and then somebody else basically
interviewing him here and one of the
things that we find out is while this
person is a little cloak and dagger in
terms of their identity being revealed
to us to frank castle even as well that
what we end up getting is kind of this
transition to somalia and we pick up
with agent venom now for those of you
guys who don't know agent venom is a
resoundingly popular story from marvel
comics people love it but it's basically
flash thompson who was the high school
bully of peter parker eventually getting
the venom symbiote and becoming quite
literally a black ops field agent this
guy would go on all kinds of cool
missions and stuff but that's why you
see him here basically killing a whole
bunch of people only for us to find out
that by extension of this panel the
person that frank castle is talking to
is general thunderbolt ross and when
thunderbolt ross approaches uh flash
thompson with a potential mission flash
thompson's immediately on board because
he sees thunderbolt ross as a kind of
hero now from there we basically switch
over to uh to deadpool who's in france
and killing a bunch of mimes who are
there to take him out business as usual
for the merc with the mouth but of
course it's one of those things where
you basically have this realization that
general thunderbolt ross has actually
been tracking the career of deadpool for
quite some time all the way from the
instance when he first went through what
was kind of the weapons plus program but
not really spending time in the nursery
things like that but basically when wade
wilson became deadpool all the way up
until now and essentially he says like
i'm looking for volunteers for this
mission that i have going on you
volunteered for that mission there's no
reason to believe you wouldn't volunteer
for this one especially if i say there's
going to be a whole bunch of killing and
deadpool is basically immediately on
board but then following that you
transition to afghanistan where you
basically have the sheik who has some
kind of a meeting thunderbolt ross shows
up and when he's immediately told by the
bodyguards of of the sheik that like
he's in the middle of a meeting the
response of ross is i'm not here to meet
the sheik i'm here to meet the person
that the sheik is meeting with which
basically turns out to be elektra
nachios who has successfully killed the
sheik of afghanistan a virtually
insurmountable task but of course she's
not killed by the bodyguards because she
stabs them through the head with pencils
which is pretty awesome
but the other thing here and really the
hardest part to do is basically bring
frank castle on board because for frank
castle it's not a matter of simply just
killing bad guys willy-nilly right
there's usually a reason behind why he
doesn't it's the reason why he doesn't
kill just any drug runner he usually
like lets the smaller guys go so we can
find the bigger guys he kills the bigger
guys and then he mops up the smaller
guys later on but he's not just an
arbitrary killer but there's got to be a
motivation behind why this is happening
and that's really what goes on when it
comes to thunderbolt ross appealing to
frank castle it is in a lot of ways
manipulation but there is a kind of
undercurrent here and in fact this will
come to fruition if we end up you know
basically going through the entirety of
thunderbolts going into the last volume
which if we do this would only be about
four videos long uh because there's only
about four or five volumes i think but
the general gist of this is that frank
castle ultimately goes on board with
thunderbolt ross and of course being
rescued from 400 different henchmen who
are all basically there to kill frank
castle which is normal for frank that
while he doesn't have the firepower
himself to take them all out with
thunderbolt ross he basically does now
one of the things to know here is that
thunderbolt ross is the red hulk right
it's one of those things that basically
happened with his character prior to the
events of this story now to provide a
little bit of explanation and some
context here most all of you are aware
that thunderbolt ross has continually
been hunting the incredible hulk over
the course of his entire career but what
had happened is during the events that
led into planet hulk and eventually
world war hulk when the incredible hulk
himself had basically been exiled from
earth by the uh by the illuminati that
thunderbolt ross had actually just sort
of lost his purpose in life because his
entire life had been defined for so long
by hunting the hulk once the hulk was
gone there was really nothing else this
combined with the fact that betty ross
had basically died left him with
seemingly nothing it was around that
time that he was approached by a group
of villains calling themselves the
intelligentsia who were basically kind
of a re-worked version of what used to
be the enclave and marvel comics back in
the day basically a group of super
intelligent people who wanted to conquer
the world through a combination of
intelligence and technological means but
they basically enabled the circumstance
under which general thunderbolt ross
would become the red hulk and so he's
kind of been that way or had been that
way for quite some time and so what's
going on here is you initially have a
meeting that takes place between red
hulk and cottagaya now we're not
entirely sure why this is happening we
will find out as we get to the end of
the story but him basically meeting with
what are essentially the rebel forces is
done for the purpose of helping them get
rid of the existing dictator a guy named
awa and the whole point behind this is
that getting rid of him as general
thunderbolt ross puts it will liberate
the entire place and where their fear is
that they could potentially be trading
one dictator for another thunderbolt
ross basically establishes that he has
no intention of ruling the land that
instead he basically means to get rid of
the dictator and then allow them to rule
in their stead now of course while this
seems like a very humanitarian and
altruistic thing it's going to end up
turning out that there's a lot more
going on behind the scenes than anything
else and so what ends up going on here
is that with the thunderbolts basically
already on the island or at least some
of them there that you end up having
them immediately launching an attack
against the forces of uh of dictator awa
for the purpose of just kind of like
neutralizing them and being able to
create a beach head on the island by
being able to get a foothold and sort of
set up some kind of an encampment and
then go from there but what's so
baffling to them at least to everybody
except for general thunderbolt ross is
that these forces these military members
of awa's army all have access to
gamma-powered weapons now the reality
here is that gamma-powered ordnance is
is banned worldwide right it's one of
those rare instances of marvel comics
when you have a weapon that's so extreme
that's basically just banned completely
and that's where the concern comes into
play because they find themselves asking
like how in the world do these guys
manage to get their hands on gamma
irradiated weapons right gamma-powered
weapons and that's when you transition
back to two weeks ago and what you end
up doing is picking up with this
hilarious moment where literally red
hulk is like look upon my worksheet
mighty and despair and deadpool's like
what the [ __ ] does that mean
right no clue what that means not only
that but what this is also designed to
do is show us how they were initially
able to gain a foothold on the island in
the first place and that getting to
madriport which is basically a city
where crime reigns supreme one of the
things to understand about madrapor
there are no real authority figures here
right like when you go to madrid you
paid your money and take your chances
but you could be killed by anybody for
virtually anything and all anyone's ever
going to do is turn a blind eye but
almost every criminal activity in some
capacity comes out of mad report even
organizations like shield will not go
into mad report right they leave that
place alone because if shield agents
went into madrid for everybody in magi4
would turn on shield they would kill
them all and then nobody would say
anything right like that would basically
be yet their agents would literally just
go missing so major poor is the place
you don't mess with it's basically the
south side of chicago but the thing
about this is that you also have kind of
arms and armament that are brought
together by thunderbolt ross and the the
thunderbolts themselves for the purpose
of allowing them to launch their
campaign for example frank castle gets a
bulletproof vest that's gamma irradiated
which can essentially stop virtually
anything outside of the most extreme
level ordnance borderline nuclear so
more than enough for him to be able to
hold his own on this mission because
without that frank castle's just gonna
get shot to pieces right just kind of
destroyed but then what you also have is
them basically stealing a vessel and
arriving to the island it's initially
just elektra and deadpool who are really
doing reconnaissance more than anything
else but also because of their
capabilities and the reason why is
because each person here has a very
unique trait for somebody like uh like
like venom for example agent venom using
gamma irradiated weapons on him is
enough to overpower and destroy the
venom symbiote but for somebody like
deadpool it's not really going to affect
them his healing thought his healing
factors so incredibly extreme for
someone like elektra she's so nimble and
agile that she would basically be able
to overcome virtually any of the odds
they end up going against the problem
here is that where they were expecting
to get onto the island with virtually no
resistance whatsoever as soon as they
get there there's immediately an army of
people who be set on them right now the
funny thing is that they basically start
kind of shouting at them and talking to
them right and then firing at them and
of course deadpool ends up getting
electra out of there and saying like
there's just too many here but once they
get into the water a submarine actually
rises up and that's what it leaves them
to be captured now the funny thing here
is that these people start addressing
deadpool and elektra and deadpool
doesn't really know what they're saying
and when the response of electra is like
what in the world do you think it is
that they're saying like deadpool just
kind of imagines it in his head
deadpool imagines it in his head that
they're like oh man deadpool right like
i'm so glad you're here on our stupid
crappy island we love you so much we're
your biggest fans can you sign our guns
and he's like well sure you know just uh
pass them on over here and i'll give
them the old john hancock which of
course is not what they're saying and
they shoot deadpool in the face right so
deadpool is kind of out of commission
for the moment but the reality is kind
of snapping back to where things are
right now because remember that is
initially or really before you had
thunderbolt ross having his meeting with
the members of the rebel forces of the
militia that what goes on is that of
course it's it's really people asking
questions right things like punisher
things like agent venom they're asking
questions because in a lot of ways
thunderbolt ross is very cloak and
dagger about what they're getting into
when it comes to frank castle he's
ex-marine right when it comes to asian
venom he's currently in the military so
what they're used to is while there is
information that's left out on missions
that they go on they're not used to
missions being this cloak and dagger and
so something seems very suspicious
combined with the fact they don't
necessarily trust thunderbolt ross but
all he really says here is that you know
there is information that we need we
currently don't have it but i am
currently working on getting that
information only for us to find out that
it's actually the leader essentially
using in order to gain information right
samuel sterns now of course we'll talk
more about him here in a minute because
he becomes a pretty significant part of
the story but one of the things that
goes on is that you end up having this
bit of a conversation between red hulk
and deadpool and it's one of those
instances where deadpool was of course
being annoying as hell but red hulk knew
what he was getting into right
thunderbolt ross knew what he was
getting into when he brought deadpool on
and so it's one of those things where
deadpool's kind of like okay i have a
question and he was like you don't get
to ask questions that pool gets ignored
and so in response to that he's like you
know answer my questions and then when
your time comes to get questions
deadpool you can ask two questions right
so deadpool is really just kind of
figuring out or at least is sort of
deduced pretty fast that there's
something going on with this red
container here and even talks about the
idea of there being a green container
which we don't necessarily see exactly
what's on the other side just kind of a
person this sort of in silhouette over
there but with regards to the red
container that's the one that's holding
samuel stearns now the leader is
historically a bad guy right he's a
villain and in fact he's tried to kick
over the world on a multitude of
different occasions and in this
particular instance this is one of those
times when his history is tied directly
into the history of the red hulk because
he was part of the intelligentsia that
turned thunderbolt ross into the red
hulk now one of the things that ross had
done in a previous storyline is he had
basically sapped the leader of his gamma
radiation and essentially reduced him
back down to the intelligence that he
had before he ever became the leader in
the first place which he was by all
standards of measurement just kind of an
idiot but when it comes time for
deadpool to ask his questions he
basically asked the question did the us
air force really commission something
called the gay bomb in the 1990s now for
those of you guys who don't know that's
supposedly an actual thing and the idea
behind the military is they were trying
to find a way to develop non-lethal
ordnance and the whole basis behind the
gay bomb if it was actually if if it did
actually exist the leaks and stuff say
that it did but if it did actually exist
the whole point behind this bomb is it
would basically detonate it in a
location and it would release pheromones
that would amp people up and develop
sexual attraction where they would
basically all just start banging each
other it was quite literally alice
huxley's brave new world again it's
leaks it's rumors conjecture we don't
definitively know if that's the case but
it seems to have been the case but
getting back into the story itself you
have a bit of clarification that goes on
here in the sense that deadpool kind of
plays our eyes and ears to a degree
where his conversation with red hulk
basically reveals that there's something
in the mind of samuel stearns that red
hulk needs but because of the fact that
samuel stern's intelligence had
essentially been removed and he's been
comatose for a little while that the
idea is to essentially rejung or restart
his brain and then basically get him to
remember what it is that red hulk needs
him to know but doing it on a limited
basis right it's kind of increasing his
intelligence just enough to where he's
cognitive and functional but not enough
to where he goes back to being the
leader as we would expect him to be but
the only way to bring him back is to use
gamma radiation hence the concern there
so it's just enough gamma radiation to
bring him back but not enough for him to
become the leader again and so what you
end up also having here is of course an
attack that's being launched by uh by
frank castle alongside these rebel
forces on this particular military base
and the reason why is because one of the
things that have gone on here is that
with elektra specializing in espionage
and so on and so forth she basically
allowed herself to be captured and what
that would do is give her eyes and ears
on the inside albeit having to endure
torture and all manner of different
things but what it would also do is it
would allow agent venom to essentially
sneak aboard a citizen vehicle that
would be brought into this military base
because they were all being conscripted
into the forces or into the army of
dictator awa and that's really how he
functions but what howa does is he
actually goes to the citizens around the
country and essentially takes something
from them that matters the most to them
kids or family or something like that or
even just approaches them and says like
your life is really really harsh come
serve in my military and i'll make your
life better or you'll get your kids back
or something along those lines right
something to force people to join their
cause hence the reason why the rebels
see the members of awa's army as
basically traitors or they see them as
people that betrayed their own people in
order to join the forces of awa because
in a lot of ways those rebels look at
general iwan or just kind of like no
matter what it is right no matter what
he promises you you should never be
willing to join this guy right
regardless of what it is you should even
let your children die as opposed to
joining this man and so again it's one
of those crazy situations because you
basically have the attack that's
launched by the rebel forces frank
castle kind of oversees it to it a
little to a degree but ends up going to
a bridge to destroy it because of the
fact that the guys in the forces will
immediately call for reinforcements and
that'll basically end up leading to
bridge being destroyed and those
reinforcements won't be able to arrive
so you know kind of a small and
intelligent tactical decision but where
you also have the forces here who end up
turning their arms and turn their guns
on the rebels who were shooting from the
trees it allows agent venom to basically
overtake those guys and bring the entire
conflict to a halt and so what you end
up having here is this recognition or
this realization that the person that's
interrogating elektra nachios and
basically this kind of secret mercenary
that nobody really seemed to know about
is philip stern now philip stearns is
also known as madman he's of course the
brother of samuel stearns the brother of
the leader but the way this worked is
that philip stearns initially idolized
the incredible hulk and like wanted to
do the kind of things the incredible
hulk did and so what he ended up doing
was basically subjecting himself to just
a litany of gamma radiation tests and
all kinds of crazy stuff it ended up
giving him insane levels of superhuman
strength but he also ended up developing
multiple personality disorder and what
this did is it basically broke his mind
and so when that happened you end up
having these instances where sometimes
he's a good guy sometimes he's a bad guy
and it allows marvel to have him switch
sides based on which personality is a
dominant personality at the time in this
instance it's the bad guy right and he
really has an ulterior motive that he's
working on here but we don't entirely
know what it is that he's trying to
achieve of course again we'll find out
because this is really the core plot of
the story the goal of philip stearns and
what it is that he's trying to do and so
what you end up having is red hulk who
basically shows up with samuel stearns
alongside deadpool to like agent venom
and those guys now agent venom knows
exactly who the leader is and even even
like frank castle knows but frank
castle's not there at the moment and in
fact deadpool even told the red hulk you
do know what's gonna happen when frank
castle gets here and he sees the leader
standing here he's gonna shoot him in
the face frank castle kills bad guys and
he doesn't ask questions the the first
opportunity he gets he's going to
eliminate that guy and of course the
response of red hulk is like well we'll
deal with that when and if we have to
and so where he shows up with a leader
immediately agent venom's just like what
in the hell are you doing are you out of
your mind right bringing this guy here
this guy is literally going to do
something and it's going to screw
everything up for us potentially even
get us killed but the reality here is
that while they're all bickering and
while they're all arguing there's
suddenly a gunshot that comes out of
nowhere and just like deadpool said he
would as soon as frank castle showed up
and saw the leader was standing there he
shot him in the head and so following
that the red hulk immediately freaks and
then basically like like just punches
frank castle into a tree and then
literally just grabs samuel stearns and
just takes off right just runs off and
so at that point it turns into the
question of okay well one like as far as
they're concerned with like this mission
itself it's scrubbed right like it's
totally screwed like there's nothing
they can do to recover this mission
whatever the mission parameter was even
supposed to be because they don't even
know why they were on this mission in
the first place they were just told like
it's an important thing that we have to
do by by the red hulk and like that was
it so their only real concern here is to
get electro nachos out of the military
compound and then to basically leave and
so once you have deadpool and frank
castle who get there which of course
deadpool is just kind of like okay man
like this plan is so dumb it's almost
like it's my plan and frank's like i
mean it is your plan deadpool's like oh
yeah that's right
but basically philip stearns comes out
and that was the whole idea was to get
philip stearns or at least whoever this
quote unquote mercenary was that they
had been told about from the rebel
forces even though the rebel forces
didn't know who this guy was to lure him
out to destroy this guy to kill him
incapacitate him or whatever and then in
turn basically find a way to get electra
free and so while all that's going on
what you have is them basically working
as a distraction that with frank castle
and deadpool facing off against against
madman against philip stearns what it
does is it allows flash to get inside of
the building and then basically rescue
elektra and that's exactly what what
happens right that's exactly what he
does he basically gets into that place
now of course you also do have frank
castle who uses this uh this kind of
mine right this this weapon on his chest
which he detonates and it does
incapacitate philip stern right it does
knock him out but it also leads to agent
venom rescuing elektra and of course
when she asks the question where the
hell is ross like what in the world is
going on that we end up finding out that
what ross is doing is he's basically
sitting or basically on the island using
a gamma irradiated system which we
didn't know that was on this island to
basically heal and then bring uh bring
samuel stearns back to life to basically
resurrect him right to kind of jump
start his healing factor heal the wound
in his head and then bring him back but
following this where you do have
deadpool and you have frank castle who
basically take madman into custody if we
can call it that because they may end up
be able to being able to use him as a
bargaining chip you have two other
things or really three other things that
take place the first is that with
dictator awa dead the rebel forces
immediately start maneuvering to
consolidate power the second thing that
happens is you actually end up having
agent venom that basically comes upon
what is this giant room that's just
filled with these tv screens and all
these people who were hooked up to it
with their eyelids basically being
forced open now of course we'll find out
the more significant thing about that
here in a second because there is a
scientist that after dictator always
death had tried to free them but it's
all basically too late they're all
basically gone but the third thing that
happens is that you end up finding out
that mercy is part of the thunderbolts
team now mercy was always one of my more
favorite characters if not one of the
more obscure characters from the
incredible hulk mythos she debuted back
in incredible hulk issue number 338 back
in 1987 but she was created by peter
david and the idea behind this is that
where peter david's run built on the
work of bill mantlow's run which was
focusing more on like the interpersonal
relationship between the incredible hulk
and bruce banner how bruce banner ended
up becoming the incredible hulk and the
abuse of brian banner and so on and so
forth that mercy was in a lot of ways an
analog or kind of a stand-in for this
idea that the incredible hulk simply
just couldn't be saved that kind of a
thing so if you could put a being if you
could personify this statement that like
mark ruffalo's hulk made in the marvel
cinematic universe where he said like he
tried to kill himself and like quote
unquote the other guy spit the bullet
out that's basically what this is the
entire idea behind mercy and her origin
had never believed and never really been
fleshed out the entire idea behind her
is that she was somebody who would
basically kill those who wanted to kill
themselves but just simply couldn't do
it right as though she was performing
some kind of a favor for them or
something like that she initially
appeared as a villain of the incredible
hulk trying to kill him because the
reality is that banner wanted to end his
life but the incredible hulk wouldn't
let banner die because the incredible
hulk had to be the strongest one there
is but the thing behind this is that
mercy appears here because in a lot of
ways she looks at thunderbolt ross and
she looks at samuel stearns and she
knows that seemingly thunderbolt ross is
dealing with a lot of internal struggle
he's dealing with a lot of internal
anger and in fact he did want to off
himself but she doesn't really use her
powers on him because she has been
brought in as part of the thunderbolts
team under under thunderbolt ross and so
as a result of that she's really a team
member more than anything else but she's
just kind of introduced to us as
officially being part of the team and
not a whole lot more is doing there but
the important thing here and really the
big revelation is that when you do have
mercy who basically moves away to the
rebel forces and essentially destroys so
many of those rebels because their
deep-seated desire is to destroy
themselves because they've basically
lost everything that means anything to
them that what ends up going on here is
that thunderbolt ross basically explains
to samuel stearns why it is that he's
needed in the first place and the
reality here is that samuel stearns when
he was the leader was definitively the
smartest person in the world the problem
with this is that he existed in two
different eras when he initially became
the leader and became as intelligent as
he was we lived in an analog world
newspapers tv print media and what have
you but once things moved into the
digital age and now there was
essentially a limitless source of
information that could be accessed at
any point in time that while samuel
stearns was still highly intelligent it
was more information than his brain
could possibly begin to comprehend or
even absorb and maintain and so what
ended up happening is a project was
basically devised that would turn human
beings into what were basically storage
receptacles because the human mind can
hold way more information than any
computer system could possibly even
achieve right at least for right now
anyway right the ability of the human
brain to operate as what's basically a
backup hard drive that's exactly what
this project was about and all these
people being hooked up to this machine
are basically just backup drives and
they're all connected on what's
essentially a single network so it's
easier to not think about these people
as actual people and think about them as
basically just servers that's how
they're being used now the reason why
this is so important is because what was
going on here is that philip stearns
while samuel cerns was basically out of
the picture philip stearns had this
entire project initiated because what he
was doing was literally scouring the
entirety of the internet to basically
find the source of gamma power right a
way to basically access gamma radiation
in its most pure form and by
conventional means we would look at this
and say well why doesn't he just expose
himself to more gamma radiation or
something like that but he had already
done that what he was looking for was to
essentially attain some measure of
godhood and so that's why all these
people were hooked up because literally
the entire like the secret is out there
somewhere but it can only really be
interpreted by somebody with the level
of intelligence that the leader had and
so while the the intention of the
original program was to use human beings
as servers for backing up information
the hope of philip stearns was to use
all these people as a way to basically
channel all this information in comb
through the information and then find
what it was that he needed right so
think of it along the lines of there's
just a giant database out there but the
database is in spanish you only speak
english and the only way to be able to
translate that spanish information to
english is to hook up a whole bunch of
people to a computer and then use their
minds as translators but that's when the
information is also brought to light for
like deadpool and frank castle and those
guys because they didn't know that's
what was going on but the reason why
this location was chosen is because
there were only three locations in the
world that were basically particle
accelerators for gamma radiation i.e the
ability to utilize gamma radiation in
its most pure form for virtually
anything that you wanted to do two of
them are known by the federal government
at the highest levels but only the
current government is aware of it the
third one is actually in secret that not
even the current government knows about
and thunderbolt ross was the one who
helped build it and so basically
operating behind the scenes and using
gamma radiation for his own purposes and
so that's when you end up having
deadpool in them who basically bring in
philip stern and when deadpool's just
kind of like yeah man we defeated philip
stern man like we you know i took his
collar but i took away his ability to
transform the response of thunderbolt
ross is like no man like the caller has
nothing to do with his ability to
transform and then immediately madman
just like emerges and starts attacking
everybody now the funny thing about this
is that this conflict ends quite readily
and the reason why is because what
samuel stearns essentially does here is
that while philip stern couldn't really
access all this information because of
the safeguards put in place by samuel
stearns when the project was originally
launched quite literally a giant
password that what ended up happening is
that samuel stearns gives the passcode
to philip stearns and what it does is it
allows philip to access all the
information in the minds of all these
people at the same time and when that
happens quite literally his head
explodes right he just can't process
that sheer amount of information and he
ultimately dies and so what ends up
happening is that samuel stearns kind of
looks around and says okay there is
something that we do need to worry about
right he says like i don't know what
exactly that is we're gonna do but i do
know that he was making something down
here by something that left the island
three days ago on a boat or some kind of
a shipping vessel and i think we need to
find it i think that if we don't that
millions of people are going to die so
what was supposed to be a ragtag team
just sort of thrown together by
thunderbolt ross for the purpose of
essentially sweeping up the mess that he
had created at one point in time by
basically getting rid of this gamma
facility and then them just kind of
stumbling across what was basically the
attempt by philip stearns to access all
the information that existed in the
world at the same time while that was
the initial intention now it's to stop
whatever it is that philip stern set
loose in the world which is just some
gigantic gamma-irradiated being which is
really really cool to be honest with you
guys but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace